die gäste gestern piste ok 62 x 56 hoch
206 kids und herzlich willkommen zu
einem neuen video
heute habe ich jemanden mit dabei der
ein bisschen so wie hast du das nicht
eingenommen hatte ich davor gesagt
vielleicht habt ihr gerade ihm gesehen
habe dann wenn es jetzt bis auf die
knochen blamiert leute wie machen heute
eine challenge wir sind intim jump
league und die challenge lautet bevor
jemand von uns eine kiste öffnen da
fliegt er von einem anderen rechner
aufgabe gestellt die erreichen aufgabe
muss er richtig beantworten wenn er sie
falsch beantwortet dafür die kiste nicht
öffnen und hat auch keine chance die
nummer zu versuchen dann ist es erledigt
ok rechenaufgabe für dich da wurzeln
lanka debatte immer gemacht wurzel 121
alter
du kannst mir weil auch meine ständige
gäste 3383 oder so nein 11 okay dann ist
ein acht hoch drei ist doch ich 1121
wurzel 121 ehrlich gesagt 883 für mich
okay gut ok 83 64 alter 8 und das land
das an diesem ort so niemand früh
auswendig alter 38 gemein als echte aber
ich weiß ich muss selbst außer damit ich
noch kontrollieren kann
64 512 jedoch oder acht mal acht bis 14
jahren 64 x 8 60 mal 80 480 x 60 x 7 ist
die pflanze nicht ob's stimmt dabei sein
okay ist auf jeden fall einfacher an dem
alter
okay das jedoch drehte sich das nicht
reinschauen hast so recht natürlich
nicht ich hab mit 35 33 hoch 327 nie der
toll dass ich scheiße ich bin da nicht
mehr 4 x 7 x 05 14 vorüber vorläufig so
abnormale ja ich bin doch hier ich habe
doch nur mit sprache zu tun nix mit
machten die juristen die können nur
reden gemacht
da könnte ich einiges 6 x 3 x
66 x 3 x 208 6 x 3 x 6 passt fast passt
fast etwas okay zwei hoch 3 x x 112 3
ist achtmal 05 15 12 ja okay du bist
auch genau nebeneinander okay für dich
habe ich 63
und für mich war mein andere okay du
hast einen kuchen und der kuchen ist was
mit 500 gramm schwer jaja es sechs gäste
wie groß oder wie viel wie kein stück
noch gab sich aufgepasst was war meine 6
3 6 3 6 3
hattest du da gamba 6 500 kann man
glaubt nicht dass durch sechs teilen das
ist aufgabe der macht
okay das ist 80 und jacobi zwischen 83
und 84
das richtig 118
das sind 36 das sind 100
216 nächste kiste gefragt hast einfach
einfach ich hab gesagt zwischen 83
ich glaub ich hab keine einfache einfach
einfach einfach 3
ich hab keine richtig kommt nochmals
nein eigentlich nicht
wenigstens im spiel gleich hier wissen
gar nicht so schlecht wird wie heißt
chris beck ist der kester piste ok 6256
hoch 280 ja und ich habe auch noch
gleich mal ein aber nicht kannst du
schon mal überlegen wie schnell du am
anfang hab ja ja nein wahrscheinlich ich
bin liebe dich ist der differential
quotient der funktion zeichnen sie bitte
den grafen der punkt jetzt es gibt keine
gibt eine 50
ich bin dumm aber lass dich gehalten
er war zu spät war zu spät wissen schon
eine map alter schwede
okay wir haben auf jeden fall einfachere
aufgaben nehmen sollen
es ging alles so schnell angegangen sie
war nicht schlecht aber die aufgaben zu
lange gedauert
fakt ist ich glaube ich hätte nicht die
neurone matheaufgabe ich auch nicht
jener kisten geschafft hat locker mehr
geschafft nein ich bin tot was wie heißt
du hast du was ich heiße jean genet okay
ich heiße mimoun das treffen
ich bin hier auf dem auf dem flughafen
platz auf zahlt kann mastermind sterben
wird wenn also an geheimen statt da hab
ich halt genauso an wie design game
engine ich habe für so rossi
da bist du hier her oder ich selig
pressebox der typ ist ein bisschen
social ja da guckst du doof ich bin
richtig kacke gehört aber junge die
wussten sich nach der einheit na ja so
als ob ich hab eigentlich eine von denen
es auf eine zuschauerin von man denkt
sich jetzt auch mein gott und den schaue
ich schon meinen job lag das ist richtig
bitter ein herbst wie bei jeder fahrt
hinein und meines tornister ich hab mir
überlegt überlegt ob ich mal auf ein
leben hey das war doch gar nicht so
eröffnet das war damals verdammt
aber wie haben so schlecht zu kippen das
einfach bitter hatte ich versuche es
noch was für mich war das
durchschnittliche junge kommt wieder
raus oder ist das eine das trap setzt
sich keine rail motor auskommen da komme
ich heraus klar dass sie klar jetzt wird
er den 1
herr wie er mich tage der junge ich hab
doch nichts du ratte jeder woanders
du bist das konto hat das ist so eine
sache
so eine ratte alter ich habe so
schlechte sachen warum tage der mich so
eine realistische stern ja ich hab halt
was ist das für ein verbot verwies dich
doch das ist nur richtig eklige stats
spieler so kühl geburt gold bohrt ja
aber corp ihr täglich der mich da
geteilter elisa [ __ ] jungen aber okay
leute das war es von der rechten
challenge schlechter kopfrechnen wieder
genannt aber wenn es unten verlinkt auf
jeden fall
wir müssen es nochmal machen dann nicht
mehr so dumm war aber das war nicht mein
tag geladen hatte ich muss da mal mein
abi machen
beim abi konnte ich so gut kopfrechnen
aber jetzt leute noch 23